c'est un retour dans les yvelines pour
benoît hamon une réunion publique à la
verrière dans son ancienne
circonscription des militants du
mouvement générations point s des
sympathisants de gauche des curieux plus
de 200 personnes ont assisté à ce rendez
vous je voulais voir un petit peu ce que
benoît hamon propose et quelle est sa
réaction par rapport aux logiciels aux
présidentielles moi vraiment c'est le
programme de benoît vraiment déjà des
idées
le côté humain aussi écologique est
revenu universel développement
écologique ou encore création d'outils
démocratiques innovants les idées de
benoît hamon le fondateur de génération
point est soit aussi à l'horizon les
élections municipales de 2020 je
m'appliquerai je m'appliquerai lors des
échéances municipales pour essayer de de
favoriser ou le passage de certaines
communes à gauche ou le maintien
d'autres serre est de faciliter à la
fois l'union et le rassemblement et puis
vraiment le grand renouvellement aussi
des dés
du paysage politique sauf au territoire
et riom une dynamique déjà enclenché sur
le territoire avec près de 800 adhérents
yvelinois exemple avec le conseil
municipal de la verrière composé de
membres de génération point s
malgré une majorité communiste on sait
que moi je suis communiste donc
effectivement j'ai une analyse et une
analyse politique est différente de
celle de benoît bien sûr après la gauche
et est multiple et on a besoin de tout
les toutes les sensibilités
pour réunir le maximum de monde autour
d'une autre politique
un appel au rassemblement de la gauche
avant 2019 et les élections européennes